what we're doing is uh
we're tempting the mind
to stay in that first mind aspect in the
functioning of the ego tripartite
by generating uh the fear and triggering
the fear response and the world's power
reactivity
okay um and it doesn't take much to do
that to people
okay so you can keep this
in a normal let's say one person so a
normal g
was uh and we're just going
in i'm not over here predicting ahead of
time
that's not what i'm doing as he triggers
my mind
right here he triggered he triggered me
and got the will to power
and so in in that is where i do my
release
and find the technique
okay something different would be
me predicting ahead of time and i'm
you're just taking advantage of knowing
what's coming in
if this technique is so simple this g
was this
environment is so simple that you have
to
not predict you have to release
and then secondly um you're never
muscling you're never muscling
okay but some don't realize that they
don't real they don't see that
so we add a second guy and that would be
enough
to amplify and make visible so i'm going
and you see i'm stuck on him you see as
i pick my technique
the mind has to find the uh
so
[Music]
so you see i never lose the other guy
my mind is constantly releasing
okay let's try
the mine's on andrew and you lost spring
so don't wait you don't need to wait
uh
[Music]
so she goes and she's counting
you